Thug somebody who you worked with
um obviously he's in a tough situation
uh for Young Thug
that was on one of your kind of like
hold over
uh to eat the Justin till EP yep me and
Thug got another joint in a can that I I
love a lot that I actually like more
than what's up but what's up just fit
that uh that um that project a little
bit better because I needed some Tempo
but um Thug man real one bro he's always
there whenever I need like any advice
you know what I'm saying whenever I
needed anything bro he's just super
genuine you guys recorded those together
yeah we recorded both of them together
what's his process compared to yours
like man I gotta I can't write when I'm
with him because he does everything off
the top so I'm like [__] I gotta do
the same [__] but even if I were to like
write some stuff he's patient he's with
whatever like with whatever but I try to
just keep up with him that's my goal to
just keep up at the pace he records but
still come up with some cold [__] right
you've been with a lot of artists who's
got the fastest Pace writing or
recording
Doug Doug yeah yeah
that's fair
who's on the new album besides we got
the new Anderson but you and Anderson
should do a new album together by the
way like yeah like like do like a 10
pack yeah that'd be crazy no it'll be
you know it's because I think our
chemistry on record is is so good
because he's really like one of my best
friends I don't have too many friends to
be honest he's a great guy he's one of
my best friends for real and so um so
Anderson's on the album who else
um I'm not quite sure yet and I don't
want to say a name just because I may
they might not make it or that song may
not make it in a grand scheme but I'll
let you know before it comes out for
sure you don't know one other for sure
no I don't I swear really bro you you
know what's the album coming out I don't
know
what's the name of the album
I don't know
just an idea
I'm sorry is it coming out and is it
coming out by the summer time yeah it
should okay and you don't have the
[__] name yet just tell me I'd rather
not say nah I'm dead ass you don't know
the name no I'm dead you could just look
at me and be like you know what bro I'd
rather not say all right
I don't know for sure I don't know for
sure that's my answer like I know the
name what I'm thinking of but it ain't I
don't want to sit here and promote a
name that ain't the name no more was
there a verse on this new album that you
know the name of a verse that song that
you felt like you might have got bodied
on a verse a verse I'm just now I'm
fishing for guest rapper verses well do
you think there's somebody on your new
album that might have bodied you on the
song
or came closer made you be like oh that
was close damn no no I like that
so what you're saying is everyone gave
you throw away verses on your own nah
[__] Ain't gonna do that [__]
it's not too many feet I literally got
like two features bro so you do know you
have features but they're not bro listen
you know I don't like to say the feature
into that paperwork I'm I'm kind of a
jinx hoe right like if we're both
walking and it's a pole we ain't
splitting that pole okay you know what
I'm saying if there's a crack on the
floor I ain't stepping on that don't
step on crack you know what I'm saying
just smoke it it is I just say it's very
hard in L.A and I step on some sort of
crack somewhere it's everywhere or it's
more fentanyl absolutely but um shout
out to that fetty WAP you know I mean
speaking of this shout out to fam [__]
that [__] crazy I wonder if fetty WAP
knew when he named himself that that
there would be a drug like named after
him like eight years later you know that
was like the most deadly [__] ever
that's like killing all half of the
country pretty crazy